SCOTT MAYFIELD ON THE BENCH IS
THE ONLY DEFENSEMAN OF THE E AT
NHL
500 WITH 24 WINS,
BACK THE OTHER WAY.
PA TRON NO LOOKING TO HELP OUT.
WILL
WITH 71 POINTS.
AND HIS A PERIOD SO FAR.
>> GOOD STUFF, JOHN.
HE HAS FIVE
THE FIRST TIME REEVES IS AT THE
GARDEN.
ANDREWS LEE IN THE
>> THAT IS HIM >> 5:10 TO GO HE
FIRST
PETAKEN AWAY BY
MATTHEW.
RACES IN AND GO DOWN
THE BOARDS.
LOOKS
ANTHONY ALWAYS PUTS UP GOLTY
KILLER FOR THE RANGERS.
HE AND THEN,
OF
COURSE WE TALKED ABOUT LEE.
HE IS S
THE GOAL TENENOD PASS THROUGH A
NELSON.
DOBSON.
BARZAL.
GOODOD
HE RELEASES AT THE RIGHT TIME
AND THE PASS COMES RIGHT
FOFO
POWERPLAY SECOND IN THE LEAGUE.
FOX.   THE WHOLE TEAM,
SAM, THEY ARE HEALTHIER NOW.
THEY FOUND THEIR INTO SOROKIN.
>> PRETTY TIGHT.
AS HE ROBBED HIM
AGAIN.    LANE.
DE FLECKED DEFLECTIONS TO REAVE
TRYING TO FIND IT.
AND HE GETS IT F F
PICKED UP BAY LAFOURCHE.
UP
QUICKLY AND SEE HOW -- THIS IS
SLOW MOTION D HIT THE OUTSIDE O
SCORININICE, RANGERS'  IN THEM
HE GETS
OSTROM SAVES THE FACE.